it is time for drew's news your good
news mama bird feeding you that good
news worm okay so you're one of my
nearest and dearest and we work
alongside of each other every day when i
just walked up to you it was like
walking up to
you know i think your friends are your
mirrors yes and so what do you think i'd
like to see where is drew barrymore
that's what i'd like to know you look i
mean you always look amazing but what
[Applause]
i feel like i look like jlo or something
and i you know i think i
could ever have said that in my life
because you do look like jlo and you
look like
some glamazon alien beauty what happened
like what is wow i know isn't it crazy
the power of hair makeup and wardrobe i
am telling you what i love about chris
appleton charlotte tilbury and brandis
danielle what they have done
is they're really well intended people
who want to
show you what's possible visually but
really take you through how you can feel
good because the better you feel
the better you're going to not only
behave yeah but receive and just walk
through life like do whatever it takes
to build that confidence so you can go
out there and conquer that day yes
yes
well how come you get a big makeover and
i just look like ross matthews like can
i get a little can i just try that hair
yeah
i have so much hair to spare oh
it's not bad it's better on you better
on her well let's get to some because
first up we're traveling again i'm so
proud to say and excited to announce the
new york times reports that people are
taking trips inspired by their favorite
tv shows people are flooding to wyoming
to get a taste of yellowstone and i know
my favorite show
some people are heading to the uk to
tour bridgerton style castles and drink
high tea and scotland's tourism board
even developed a 12-day outlander tour
of scotland complete with historic
places
palaces fortresses and gorgeous highland
views do you have any of these
destinations you want to go to because
of tv shows like i watched emily in
paris so now i'm like obsessed i want to
just go spend time in paris now and wear
beautiful clothes
um
well i definitely don't want to go to
the handmaid's tale please no
um
what's that place called oh other than
hell uh i can't think of the name um
i don't want to go to gilead no um
and uh no but i'll get back to you on
that one i watched house of gucci again
house of aguchi and i wanted two things
to go to italy or olive garden that's
what i wanted to go
anyway yeah next up we all need to have
a little bit of fun remember fun you
guys right
i'm having it right now me too
but are you getting enough of something
called type 2 fun let me explain what
this is the washington post reports type
2 fun is actually something it's a term
that comes from the climbing community
like the mountain climbing community oh
i'm so relieved right
because it does it does sound like
something scary type 2 fun but it's it's
good i think it can apply to all of us
and they describe it as the kind of fun
that hurts a little bit so in terms of
climbing this could mean like climbing
up a mountain but doing it at winter you
know or at night so it's fun but it's
extra challenging okay and for the rest
of us there are here's some examples for
us like a new year's polar bear dip you
know when you jump into an ice cold lake
um or eating like a hot pepper contest
like that hurts but it's yeah these are
all such
common examples no
i'll give you two birth and tattoos
those are fun everybody's doing it yeah
they're painful
and yet it hasn't stopped anybody
i've also been to a happy hour that hurt
the next day
exactly hangovers birthing and tattoos
no i just got good old-fashioned type 1
fun for me you know i don't need danger
okay well next up people report someone
called 9-1-1 when they saw this big boy
on a rooftop in pennsylvania
firefighters arrived oh my god the dog
casually turned around and walked back
through a balcony door into the
apartment it turns out he just likes to
sunbathe he's a real life snoopy oh my
god
no that's it that's the story like the
dog is not in trouble the dog just likes
to kick it up there like snoopy do you
know what that dog's favorite word is
i thought you were gonna say
the dog's favorite word is type two [ __ ]
[Music]